Canada says it will allow the u.s.
extradition case against a high-ranking
Chinese telecom executive to proceed
huawei chief financial officer mung Wong
sue is accused of conspiring to defraud
banks by misrepresenting the company's
relationship with a suspected Iranian
front company China says it is utterly
dissatisfied with and firmly opposes the
decision well Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau is dealing with a growing
scandal tonight it involves what he
allegedly told a top official to do
about a major company involved in a
corruption investigation correspondent
Julian Turner picks up the story from
outside the Canadian Embassy in
Washington I and my staff always acted
appropriately and professionally
that's Canada's Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau continuing to resist a
groundswell of calls for his resignation
his office treading water as a scandal
that erupted inside his cabinet now
threatens to drown the entire
administration our government will
always focus on jobs but Trudeau is
holding fast to his main line of defense
my job as Prime Minister has always been
to stand up for Canadians
Trudeau's own former attorney general
and Justice Minister claims his office
launched a consistent and sustained
campaign over many months to get her to
drop charges against a Canadian company
SNC Lavin is one of the world's largest
construction and engineering firms and
Jody Wilson reybold's planned to slap
its leadership with bribery and fraud
charges in testimony before the Canadian
Parliament Wednesday
Wilson Raybould outlined what she calls
Trudeau's bold-faced intimidation
tactics there were many other
inappropriate conversations and attempts
at political interference that occurred
I believe where it got even more
heightened were what I described as the
veiled threats if true it's a dramatic
fall from grace for Trudeau a young
energetic Liberal prime minister who
grabbed the world's attention a decade
ago thanks in large part to his easy
rapport with world leaders high-profile
friendships with President Obama and
spats with President Trump over free
trade now Trudeau's awful week is poised
to get worse
Canada's Conservative Party sharpens its
knives a textbook case of government
corruption with those at the very top of
the Prime Minister's Office implicated
Trudeau's office told Fox News just a
short while ago quote we completely
disagree with the former attorney
general's characterization of the events
no matter how this shakes out though
Canadians will get their say Trudeau's
up for reelection in October and what
polls show is going to be a very tight
race Shannon Julian Turner thank you
very much